A single strike
could reshape our world
and the only thing that can stop it
is science
It wasn't until a couple hundred years ago we even knew that asteroids existed
finding asteroids before they find us is critical
We use telescopes to take pictures of the night sky
a moving point of light reveals an asteroid
we use this radio dish antenna from the Raider echo
we can determine their shape, orbit, and size
preventing an asteroid strike requires engineers of every discipline and a lot of teamwork
No idea is too crazy
IMAX invites you
to learn about the science
the technology
and the heroes who are Earth's secret weapons